Hello and welcome, everyone. It's ActInf
Lab Livestream number 44.2, and it's May
25, 2022. Welcome to the ActInf
lab. We're a participatory online lab
that is communicating, learning, and
practicing applied active inference.
You can find us at the links on this
slide. This is a recorded and an
archived Livestream, so please provide
feedback so we can improve our work.
All backgrounds and perspectives are
welcome, and we'll be following video
etiquette for live streams. If you want
to learn more about the live streams or
any other projects at Active
Inferencelab, check out
activeinference.org. Okay,
today in 44.2, we are in our third
discussion around the paper,
therapeutic alliance as Active Inference
the Role of Therapeutic Touch and
Synchrony from 2022 by the authors
listed here. And Ian and I had a dot
zero where we contextualized and went
over some of the outline of the paper.
Then we had a great discussion last week
with several of the authors in the dot
one, and today we're here with some of
the authors, and we'll see who else
joins. And we'll be continuing that
discussion around the paper. We left a
few threads, but also we can just take
it wherever people would like to go.
And we'll begin just by saying hello.
People can say anything they want.
And how is this week different than last
week? How are we approaching this paper
differently? Or what would we like to
resolve or address in this two that
was stimulated by the dot one or that we
didn't get to in the one? Feel free to
add anything in that area. So, I'm
Daniel. I'm a researcher in California,
and one piece in the two
that I'd like to explore would be what
are the entities that we're discussing
here at what scales, and how to think
about that in terms of their generative
model and so on. And I'll pass to Ian.
Hello. Thank you, Daniel. And yes,
I would like to maybe pick
up on if we've got time on the topic of
synchrony this week and what types of
synchrony might we be talking about?
What things might be oscillating that
come into sort of phase lock between two
agents that have the potential to
synchronize and then where do they
head towards with their synchrony? And
then if we've got time, thinking about
tying this all back to some of the core
ideas about minimizing free energy and
what does that mean in a therapeutic
setting?
Yes. That's it, I think. Thank you.
Awesome. All right, any of the authors,
feel free to go for it.
Zoe, play this first.
Okay, so I'm George. I'm one of the
authors on this paper. I'm an osteopath
and researcher. And where
do I see this going forward? I pretty
much enjoyed the interaction we had last
week and very happy to kind of be left
by you guys, Ian and Daniel, and anybody
else that want to join. I think we can
definitely explore those ideas about the
synchronization to agents, and arguably
more than two agents when we operate in
a kind of not in a diadic setting, but
actually in a triadic setting. For
example, pediatric care, kind of elderly
care and so on, actually, there's an
additional agent in the whole thing.
So what do I look forward to? The
discussion kind of stimulate some
ideas about ways in which we can move
forward with this to the more empirical
state of the research.
Great. Zoe.
Hi, I'm Zoe. I'm an Osteopath as well,
based in Singapore, and I'm the primary
author for this paper. Yeah, happy to be
led by anyone that wants to where we
want to go, but definitely happy to talk
about synchrony. I think, as George
said, it would be important to talk
about not just diadic, but triadic or
otherwise, because I think that adds a
lot of depth to it. But also
it's easier to sort of discuss the
effects of synchrony and also the fact
that you can be.
Okay, lost Zoe for a second.
Anyone that wants to ask questions.
Okay. Also, Zoe, is there, like, any
other microphone to use, or could you
speak closer to the microphone?
I'm just using my laptop, so there isn't
really a microphone. I can take my
headphones off if that makes a
difference. It's fine. It's just a
little quiet, but it's fine.
Okay. Sorry. Oh, no, it's totally all
good. Just want us to check. Okay. All
right. Let us pick up with the synchrony
then. So I guess just to kind of
recall, how was this question of
synchrony approached in the active
inference literature and maybe even
outside of the active inference
literature, and then how was synchrony
approached in this paper? Why was that
such a core topic in this approach
that the authors took?
I think we started with synchrony as the
main part, mainly because when
we were talking about the therapeutic
alliance, synchrony and getting on with
the other person is kind of key. And the
way that we approached this paper,
primarily in terms of a lot of the
aspects of how we achieved that good
therapeutic alliance was through
synchrony. So that's kind of where
that's one of the reasons through active
inference. It was also about
I started the research when I was
looking at it right from sort of the
start and looking at how communication
worked and why people would want to sort
of synchronize together and why people
to implement active inference into sort
of the structure that we had. It was
important to kind of see why that would
be beneficial because we wanted to use
or we like to say that the synchrony
enables us to work together to then
therefore save free energy, be more
efficient, and then that's how we
very much used it to apply this active
inference sort of framework around
it. And so I felt that it
was very key without the synchrony
element. It was kind of the backbone
into which a lot of the aspects of
active inference in the way that we
achieve therapeutic alliance seemed to
sort of center around. Without that
connection between the different people,
we wouldn't be able to save energy to
work together, to have a better
relationship with our practitioners,
with the patients and practitioner. We
wouldn't be able to get the clinical
applications and benefits from it.
So I saw synchrony as sort of the key
medal to sort of get to where
the sort of paper was. So it was sort of
a key concept to
use in order to implement it all
together. George.
Yeah, let's say when we started
the project actually kind of putting
some ideas along the lines of how could
we apply predictive processing and
the free energy active inference within
osteopathy and within the osteopathic
setting. Synchrony came along actually
after the initial discussion
with Karl Frieston that kind of
suggested know look into this stuff
because actually could be quite a robust
way of understanding what
goes on in the clinic room when two
people are working together with a
specific kind of aim. There is
a little bit of literature in
psychotherapy kind of demonstrating that
actually the therapeutic alliance
becomes much more robust when two people
synchronize and both at the kind
of behavioral but also biological
level. And it was nothing about sort of
okay, this is about pure verbal
communication, nonverbal but primarily
by kind of copying body movements and so
on to think, okay, how can this
be applied in the context of actually an
approach that is largely hands on based
as a manual therapy? So that's where it
kind of started from. It was one way of
trying, like Zoe said, kind of looking
at therapeutic alliance when people
interact to try and understand what goes
on in the diadic setting. Kind of two
people but also a little bit beyond of
what happens when there's actually more
people involved in that therapeutic
relationship that need to be consulted,
need to be involved in the process and
so on.
That was the kind of early stage.
And then we thought that actually this
is a good way of understanding a
little bit more about how we can create
the conditions of developing a strong
kind of ecological niche that is based
on that synchrony of that sort of
understanding of that give and take.
Like a little bit like we talked about
last week, the kind of the Bird song.
People taking turns, kind of
understanding, listening, okay, acting
kind of taking on, go back and so on.
And that's sort of, in a sense, like
kind of a nice wave that goes back and
forth. But it is a kind of very nice and
tranquil kind of wave. Not a one that
just crashes and destroys everything,
but actually one where once that kind of
goes on a little bit like the pendulum
kind of analogy once you introduce that
nice pendulum kind of things happen.
That's where we sort of thought it could
be one way of exploring the whole
process of care.
Thank you, Ian.
Thank you.
I'm fascinated by the topic of synchrony
and the little bits I've read in the
literature about how measurable
things that might be able to synchronize
between one or two or more people.
So, Daniel, I think we discussed this in
the zero. So choirs
singing together, they have been shown
their heart rates kind of synchronize
with their breathing.
And I think in the paper there was some
references cited for similar sort of
stuff in drumming circles, for example.
So that really interests me and I can
kind of begin to see how in a
therapeutic setting, that kind of
synchrony could lead someone who's maybe
stressed and anxious into a kind of more
healthy increased parasympathetic
activity and that is conducive to
healing. But I've also got
these other sort of nagging things about
synchrony as well that maybe
I touched on the dot zero,
which is what are we synchronizing
towards and is it always beneficial?
So the
less kind of lockstep synchrony that you
talked about, Daniel. So maybe it's
just, let's say a child saying, mummy,
mummy, mummy, waving their arms around
and then the mum synchronize, they
synchronize their attention together.
So you get mother and child and then
you've got a choice. So there's some
aspect that's synchronized. I think in
the paper it talked about the arms and
the limbs and the voice kind of
synchronizing and the facial
expressions. But a
caregiver might then lead the child to a
soothing kind of parasympathetic way
soothe it. Or it might say, give it a
clip behind the ear and say, children us
to be seen and not heard and try and
stop the attention. The attention is
synchronized, but the action may
not be therapeutic.
Yeah, I'm just sort of thinking about
where you know, where just because
something's synchronized, does it mean
it's always minimizing free energy or
just because things
in the therapeutic world go in and out
of fashion? So frontal lobotomy is okay,
we don't do that anymore. But for a
while there was some kind of
synchronized thinking in the therapeutic
world that that's a good idea for
people. And there
are ideas that I hear in the wider kind
of therapy world that are fashionable
and they're being applied, but in
50 years time we may look that they may
have been leading people away from
minimizing free energy or improving
health.
My thoughts. Okay. Awesome. Yeah, a lot
there. George.
I think the interesting thing,
there are nagging questions there for
sure. The first one, do we always
synchronize and when if you don't
synchronize what we're going to do,
because clearly there are cases where we
know the therapeutic relationship is
going nowhere. We can say whatever we
can, try our best, but actually,
there is resistance to change from the
patients. We end up not understanding
each other. And arguably,
that's a relationship that will not
evolve. And, well, you might even get to
a point at the end. Maybe it'd be a good
idea to go and see a colleague of mine
kind of thing. Okay, so do we
synchronize with everybody? No, clearly
not. Is there any value understanding
this stuff by sometimes understanding
that some kind of gestures and sort of
body language and so on,
voice, sound, sort of communication
style, we're probably giving us cues
maybe to adapt a little bit to try and
synchronize a little bit better. I think
that's useful. I think important in
order to be a good communicator. I think
first and foremost, sometimes people
worry too much about the technical
skills and the ability of doing X and Y
and doing some miracles and so on.
Arguably the first thing that people
need to be in a clinical setting is good
communicator and a pretty good, nice
person. Okay? And I think if that's
there, I think we create the conditions
in good communicators likely to have
potentially better outcomes that guys
that basically don't care and sort of
they're the experts and so on. The other
question is, is it always about
minimizing free energy? Because there
are situations where
probably you want to short circuit the
whole thing, isn't it? You want to sort
of flatten a little bit of that sort of
sensory state. You want to create a
condition where the only way you
can sort of change the generative model
is actually by creating a massive
surprise, a massive prediction error
that arguably surprises the system in a
way like, wow, what just happened? And
actually, oh, okay, I don't
think it's always about minimizing free
energy, but sometimes I think you want
to shock the whole thing because the
system on the other side wants to
minimize free energy for sure.
If I'm a kind of chronic pain patient
and I'm scared of moving and you tell me
to move and so on, the reaction is I
anticipate the likelihood of movement
leading to pain. I anticipate the
consequences of actions in the future,
the typical active inference model.
And I lock, I don't move. So I probably
want to short circuit the whole thing to
create a condition where it's actually
okay to move because it's not going to
cause any harm, is it,
through synchrony? Maybe it
isn't. Okay, so I think that's not,
I think, a kind of one size fits all
kind of thing. And I don't think it's
just about sort of always that
minimizing free energy because I think
creating change that is meaningful
change probably needs a little bit more
of it
needs to destroy that sort of strong
prior kind of thing so I can implant
another chip kind of thing in a
metaphorical way. And that's why we
know in some mental health conditions
why some types of drugs like catamine
and so on, create that condition that
sort of zeros. The whole thing is a bit
like you reset the button, isn't it?
The computer is stuck. What you do,
you've tried everything. You unplug the
computer and then you try again. The
whole thing reboots, isn't it? So I
think sometimes that's the analogy of
maybe what we want to achieve in the
setting is it through synchrony? I
personally, I don't know, and I'm not
entirely sure. Of course, if the people
started understanding each other, then
that creates the conditions for this
thing probably to happen. Because if you
don't understand me as a practitioner,
I don't understand you as a patient,
it's pretty hard that actually I create
the condition for change. So maybe it's
through synchrony, but again, as a sort
of big question marks, really.
Thanks. Yes. Zoe, please.
Yeah, so I think going off what I
mean, overall, the goal would be to
minimize free energy. But to be able to
do that, you have to sort of at some
point challenge it, right? You're not
going to have the same belief that you
think is the most efficient. When you're
born to when you die, the way
that you become reduced
energy is going to change over time.
You'll see that especially in sort of
pediatrics. You see it in sport.
There's a lot of studies with running,
for example, that show that the more you
run, often the more mileage that people
do when they run, the more efficient
they get. So I think free energy is,
yes, we all want to reduce it, but at
some point we've got to update it and
challenge it, right? So it won't be sort
of just this linear thing where you're
constantly just changing it. You've got
to update it and challenge it at some
point. So it will sort of be a little
bit of a roller coaster and have a few
dips where you got to take that risk to
see if there's another way that is more
efficient, that will save it more.
Whether synchrony is always necessary,
I'm not sure. I definitely think that
when you're unsure whether or
if your prior is not so precise and
you're not 100% sure that that is the
best way to do whatever you're doing,
or you're not 100% certain that your
belief explains what's going on, then I
think you're more likely to synchronize
with others. I think once you're quite
certain on what you think and what
you're going to do, then it's a lot
harder to synchronize. Like with
the cognitive sort of immunity when
you've got chronic pain, it's a lot
harder to change that because you're
convinced that you're right. You've had
this pain for years, maybe, and you know
what it's like. If you bend forward,
it's going to hurt. So why would you
bother to challenge that?
I think there's a lot of studies that
show that, especially with sort of
babies, that they synchronize with their
when they're younger the synchrony is
very consistent. Obviously they need to
work with their caregiver to get their
alleystatic needs and everything that
they need to keep surviving. But it
shows that they do still think when
they're adults but the time when they're
older or in adulthood that they do think
is when they're unsure. When something
happens and you are near that caregiver
and you don't know, you still sort of
rely on them. Say I don't know, you get
into a car accident or something and
there's a big shock and you're not sure.
Often the child will still, no matter
how old they are, will look to the
parent, obviously unless the parent is
very elderly. But generally speaking in
times of uncertainty you will look
towards someone else. So I think is
synchrony always necessary? No but I
think if you're not 100% certain with
your priors and you are questioning it
or there is a doubt of that questioning
it, then I think synchrony will play
more of a role in it and I'll
pass it back to you. Awesome, thanks.
Yeah, just thinking about beliefs in the
way that we might talk about them. Hey,
blue. Welcome. Just the way that we
might conversationally talk about
beliefs. If somebody is unsure about
something that's when they look to be
synchronized by some other informational
resource. I'm not sure what time this
thing opens so I'm going to look it up
in this way or I'm going to ask this
person or I'm not sure where to go so
I'm going to follow the crowd. We see
that kind of in the ant pheromone trail,
we see that in the social media, all
these different areas. And then
conversely when somebody does have a
more confident, more built up prior then
that's more like going their own way and
potentially being more resistant to
external contrasting information and
then translating from that one
conversational meaning of belief like I
believe that is going to open at this
time into a broader Bayesian perspective
on Bayesian brain and body and thinking
about pain and perception as also
parameters that can be seen as beliefs
in this Bayesian sense. So not always
like a psychological experienced belief
but in some statistical way it's like
they're held stances that are updated
in some way or partially or completely
by certain kinds of incoming
information. So Ian and then also this
is going to be I think very interesting
to return to the free energy
minimization and unpack what we mean by
free energy there. So Ian. Go for.
Thanks. So, yeah, I'm just sort of
wanting to check that some of
the language used in other realms of
therapy. So this idea of self regulation
and co regulation, are we saying
here that this synchrony in the
therapeutic reliance is a form of co
regulation that we hear a lot about
in people with disorder
problems of their autonomic nervous
system? And then we say, you go to a
therapist to help co regulate your
autonomic nervous system. Is that what
we're saying as synchrony is the kind of
mechanism for co regulation which
I believe fits with what you're saying,
zoe that children need that more and as
adults we might do that occasionally.
And then I'm just thinking also other
forms of therapeutic synchrony and co
regulation. So meeting friends for a you
know, I might be having a bit of a
stressful week or a
wobble in some way, and then I meet some
friends and we kind of seek
counsel in each other, have a
synchronize our movement of our hands to
our mouth with a coffee cup or listen to
some music together, tap our feet
together. And that's a kind of
therapeutic. So are we all kind of doing
this on and off all the time?
They're my thoughts or questions.
Yes. George zoe, then? George.
Yeah. No, I just wanted to say yes.
With the co regulation. I think that we
kind of not always but I think
we do add an element to try and suggest
that we'd like to say that we in part
help co regulation and as
a practitioner to achieve sort of
recovery and reduce pain and
help. I think we all want to say that we
help in that process and that we help
regulate their sort of disruptive
pattern, whether that's inflammation,
whether that's pain, whatever sort of
metric that you want to rate
your treatment by or whatever your
treatment goals are that you're sort of
working towards. I think we all want to
say that we sort of help regulate
which ways we regulate in terms of
whether we actually
change their heart rate or things like
that. We're not always so
specific about we don't have the
research to kind of show that. But I
think certainly there is elements of
sympathetic and parasympathetic things
that we do, as well as sort of the
intent to co regulate even if we don't
sort of empirically do it or
achieve it. Whether just that
reassurance that we're attempting to
help regulate their pain,
I think is sort of the intention that I
hope that as a practitioner I am giving
off to my patients and I'll let George
speak.
I think if
you come from a manual therapy
background, a touch based, hands on
approach, one could argue, or old school
kind of beliefs in the profession,
christian Osteopathy would argue that
actually how you achieve that core
regulation, autonomic nervous system,
sympathetic parasympathetic is primarily
through the use of techniques. You use a
technique in a particular part of the
body and this affects the
parasympathetic part and so on the vagus
nerve and all that stuff that sort of
implies there is a tool by which you
can apply that stuff, treat that
particular bit and by miracle modulate
everything. I used to be there, no
longer there because the evidence isn't
strong enough to actually support those
clients on the other hand, if we add
another element, which is the element
the synchrony. And the synchrony here
goes beyond just that sort of passive
practitioner led type of intervention
into something that implies
communication, implies alignment
attuning to the environment. And the
environment there is the practitioner as
well. So the other person in the room,
the guy that is facilitating the
process. So it sort of takes us, I
think, away from this idea that
everything is about touches, everything
is about the manual stuff and so on.
But it becomes a kind of a multipronged
approach where touch matters, that
communication matters as much as touch.
And it's not a technique X, Y or NZ,
but it's actually the whole package of
care that's likely to enable us to get
there. So is it similar
I like your analogy to sort of tough day
and so on. You go out, you need to see
your friends, you need to synchronize in
a different environment because
ultimately people will talk to
each other and correlate regulate each
other even in terms of reducing
allostatic load of a tough week and so
on. There are kind of things that are
similar to what happens in the clinical
setting. One of them, we're probably
thinking about reward systems as well.
There's a sort of a participation in
something that is likely to, even if
uncomfortable, is let is going to lead
to some improvement. Maybe there's
some dopamine stuff, maybe there is a
reward pathways that are kind of
involved in the whole thing, like having
a drink in the same having a therapeutic
intervention that ultimately is going to
get me to a better state. I think it's
very analogous to moving away from the
free energy principle and to an area
that kind of works
alongside that inactivism,
the concept of sense making,
what inactivists would argue
participatory sense making. So synchrony
could be kind of also looked from that
lens, from that perspective. Whereas two
people or more than two people either in
a group having a drink and all kind of
helping each other because I listen, or
in a therapeutic setting that sort of
participatory things, making minimizing
free energy or autopoeasies for the kind
of the inactivists. Actually, I think we
sort of looking at the same phenomena,
maybe with different language, but
arguably the same kind of phenomena. I
think it's that package that probably
helps core regulation rather than just
one intervention. Thank you,
Blue. Welcome. Do you want
to add anything or ask anything?
Not right off the bat, just hi, it's
nice to be here with you guys. I'm sorry
I missed last week and I've really
enjoyed the discussions of the paper so
far. And I'll jump in, in a little bit.
I think you guys were engrossed in a
good conversation. Okay,
awesome. So the Dopamine angle and a few
other things we'll return to. But we
were talking about minimizing free
energy and I wanted to show a few images
from the textbook because even those
who have seen free energy come up in a
lot of different settings, sometimes
returning to the basics is a generator
that helps us take it in many other
ways. And for those who are maybe
focused more on the clinical setting or
have more of that background, this can
provide a little other tissues
around the connective tissue. Free
energy is being used like a connective
tissue here. It's bridging a lot of
different ideas. It's helping us connect
different sensory modalities and
therapeutic modalities. So just a few
cool images from the active inference
textbook. So here is Figure
2.3 and it's the action perception
loop and the two ways that discrepancies
related to predictions or expectations,
the two ways that discrepancies about
observations can be reduced just
qualitatively is through changing belief
and changing action. And it's some blend
of those two that individual entities
are engaged in in this action perception
loop. And then when we're specifically
talking about free energy, there's some
type of equation,
this is like a simple form of it that
is going to make that discrepancy
minimization tractable and possible
to calculate for at
least us doing statistics from outside
the system, if not for the system itself
to do. And what is the real
sort of hidden goal?
Is this minimization of true surprise.
But the minimization of true surprise is
intractable or it's inaccessible. And so
free energy serves as like this upper
bound. Whereas if we can reduce this
upper bound, we're getting implicitly
closer to this asymptotic
reduction of surprise. So who
is doing this reduction of surprise that
relates to the entity question
what is the entity that's actually doing
free energy minimization? And so what
are the entities that we're talking
about here? What does it mean to
minimize free energy?
I liked how earlier it was brought up
when sometimes where that free energy
minimization was going with the flow and
then sometimes when there was a flow
disrupt. So what is free energy
minimization and what are the entities
and how are we modeling that? Ian and
then anyone else?
Thanks. Yeah, that question of what are
the entities and linking it back to
George's point about sense making and
inactivism. So in the paper there
was some really interesting stuff on
realizing that we're all alike in
the therapeutic alliance and relating
that back to sense making. I'm thinking
that therapeutically or in
a manual therapy or meeting friends,
the outcome might be I'm not a
weirdo, I haven't done anything wrong,
everything's okay. Again, I'm relaxed
and that's therapeutic. So I'm amongst
people who are very much alike me. And
that's the sense making. There's the
pattern recognition. I'm a valuable
member of my tribe, however you want to
describe it.
But we're never completely identical.
Or are we? I don't know.
The proposal in the paper is that that's
the ultimate realization that we're all
alike. And I can kind of see. That
that's a kind of relieving thing to
realize. But we're similar.
I'm similar to my pet dog in that I've
got eyes and I breathe and my heart
beats and I can synchronize in some ways
with that, and it feels nice, but my dog
can't help me do my accounts, for
example. So,
yes, this alikeness. And how
does that fit into sense making?
Thanks, Blue. So, as I've been reading
the textbook, I've been thinking a lot
about the hidden states. And it's
interesting to think about that in terms
of using touch to kind of resolve
uncertainty about the hidden states.
Because while a state might be hidden to
the patient, when you present with some,
like, I've got a pain in my shoulder or
something like that, it might be easy
for the therapist to say, oh, that's
this, this, and I push here and tweak
this, and then it's better.
So it might be hidden to the patient but
not hidden to the doctor, or hidden to
the doctor and the patient, or hidden to
the patient but not the doctor, or the
doctor but not the patient. So it might
be like all of these things. And so it's
like working together, this kind of
synchrony to resolve uncertainty about a
hidden state. And I've thought a lot
about who's making the observation and
who's doing the state observing and who
is the state hidden to. And it brings
back the paper that you guys mentioned
in the zero the communication as active
inference because it really is like a bi
directional, harmonious kind of thing
happening. Right. Awesome. Thanks.
Yes. George.
Yeah. So actually,
starting with the hidden states, who's
observing, who's been observed? I think
the free energy model or picture the
typical representation with the two
agents and or one agent in the world and
internal states, external states and so
on. If you have the two agents, there's
something in the middle that clearly is
the ground where we kind of try
to achieve some form of alignment. And
then that sort of implies the
reading of someone else's internal
state, I think, who makes the
observation, who's been observed and so
on. I think, again, is the birdsong is a
give and take because there are clearly
situations where you may be telling your
patient that actually is nothing to
worry about, for example, where you're
not particularly sure about what's going
on and the patient can clearly read in
your body language that, no, it's hiding
something from me. Right. It's something
there that doesn't feel right.
Actually. There's an interesting
phenomena, for example, in chronic
conditions, which is the concept
of cognitive immunization,
where it's very common these days for
patient goes and sees a practitioner,
has read, has consulted with Dr. Google
to start. Dr. Google said it could be x,
Y, and Z, typically the worst case
scenario. Goes and sees doctor
number one. Doctor number one says,
yeah, you know what? Nothing to worry
about. There's nothing wrong with you.
Patient has got pain, kind of saying,
all right, I don't trust you kind of
thing, then goes and sees practitioner
number two. That comes with a different
story and yeah, okay, maybe you forget
about if forgotten about something goes
to practitioner number three and so on
and gets through a process where authors
argue that the
system becomes cognitively immune to any
new explanations because the
expectation is surely there's something
wrong with me. So clearly in those
conditions, if we take from this lens,
one could argue, yeah, as a patient,
I'm observing you, I'm kind of reading
your internal states, which is I don't
trust you kind of thing because you're
telling me something, but actually
something that potentially you don't
believe either, okay. Or this thing
about, let's do cognitive reassurance
because most nonspecific back pain or
neck pain, one cannot say that's clearly
a particular tissue responsible for the
pain, the symptoms and so on. So you
say, okay, there's nothing serious with
you, so what's wrong with me? You
clearly can't tell the patient you've
got nonspecific back pain because for
the patient that means you haven't got a
clue about what's wrong with me. Or
you're implying that something upstairs
in my head, I'm making it up. So
patients observe us for sure, and they
know when we kind of are confident and
so on, and when we're not so confident.
And maybe we're not entirely sure if
actually the whole thing is going to
happen. In the same way we observe
patients, we start observing
them when they come through the door,
when you first greet them and so on,
hi, how are you doing? Before COVID
times, shaking hands and so on were a
pretty good first kind of getting into
someone else's internal state because
just the handshake, the quality of
the amount of pressure, the confidence
and so on. There were cases say this
person is anxious, this person is down,
is depressed, and so on. And you could
get that down to when you
do clinical examination, you touch, you
observe, you feel, you palpate and so
on. That implies
that there is a lot of unconscious
stuff. That process
comes through, arrives through our
sensory, our sensorian and we
make something out of it. So I think
that's what we kind of one of the things
we try to explore through this stuff
about try to understand someone else's
internal state, predicting a little bit
of their mental state.
And that's where synchrony and that's
where alignment kind of plays that
important role because if there's no
alignment, I can't clearly guess what's
wrong going on. The stuff about
Ian, what you mentioned about sense
making and so on, sense making is
quite an interesting thing. You said,
okay, we're not like a
patient is a patient and the
practitioner is a practitioner. There is
that power differential as well.
There's the doctor, there's the patient.
When one is an expert and when the other
is an expert and things alternate the
whole thing about sense making and
actually minimization of free energy and
so on. Sense making is quite an
interesting thing too when we look at
some clinical conditions and there's
some beautiful stuff written about, for
example, mental health and inactive
approaches and looking at, for example
depression as a disorder of sense
making, for example. And you see
that sometimes with patients with
chronic musculoskeletal problems that
also have a comorbidity
they have depression. What came first?
The depression of the back or the back
pain? One could argue that if
I suffer from chronic back pain and I
can't get out of the house I can't see
my friends, I can't walk my dog, I can't
play with my children and so on the
world stops kind of making sense,
right? I don't go out because outside
is a cruel world and it's kind of full
of dangers and so on. So I stay in a
safe environment which is my home
watching telly, kind of complaining
about myself to myself and
I become depressed because I'm stuck
there. So the
therapeutic encounter that sort of nice
ecological niche in a sense creates
opportunity for sense making to
understand where there's patterns for
example, rigid behavior, rigid thinking
that actually by understanding,
by interacting can potentially start
sort of taking the patient in a
particular direction which is this
kind of road to recovery.
And one could argue that if someone
starts feeling kind
of better in themselves symptoms reduce
a little bit, can start doing a little
bit more, can start again engaging with
the world. Maybe the other stuff about
feeling miserable would get better as
well. And I think that's sometimes what
we see in musculoskeletal care is this
stuff. We don't treat mental health
conditions and I don't think we should
make those claims because they're
clearly boundaries
and competences and so on. But the
patient that has got, for example, a
chronic musculoskeletal problem and gets
better and gets an impact that impact
changes their quality of life changes
their ability to become an agent again
because pain they lost their agency
because of pain. I think that's where
the beauty of this understanding this
stuff kind of comes is you can impact
on different levels of the person of the
self that is clearly not just that
embodied self, that body but it's beyond
that embodied self. Is this
multidimensional kind of what is to
be a person kind of thing, right?
I think at times it's about kind of
reading the other understanding the
other guy's internal state is about sort
of doing the right thing at the right
time. Because I know there's a cue that
tells me maybe if I do this stuff this
could be really one way of getting
surprising the system in a very positive
way. Okay, so I've just been
pontificating. Zoe yes.
Yeah. I think oh, gosh. Let me take
my hand down. Okay. Yeah. I think
similar to what George said on sort of
it's a bird song. I think there's
different aspects know? Yes. Generally
on the technical, the physiology or the
anatomy side, then the practitioner is
always obviously more the expert. But I
think there's certain things where maybe
you're looking at a patient or you're
still trying to examine them and the
patient is still going to be the expert
in their pain. And so you might be
tossing and turning between a few
diagnosis, say, and then the patient
suddenly comes up with like, oh yeah,
by the way, and then what you were
thinking completely goes out. So I think
you completely read them. There's always
going to be sort of hidden states that
you don't know about and then you're
always on the lookout in case the
situation is changing or maybe they
don't want to tell you exactly what it
is and you think something's missing.
That intuition that maybe there's an
element of this that you're not getting,
or suddenly they got worse and you're
wondering, well, what happened? What
changed? What goes on? And then you
find out that.
Their. Child'S been really sick or
something, or their work has been really
stressful or something else has
happened, excluding that they haven't
said that you kind of pick up on. So I
think there's that where you're
inferring what that other person means.
And there's definitely you're watching
them, they're watching you, and you're
kind of still deciding what's going to
happen based on what you think is going
on throughout treatment.
There's no set treatment for certain
things as well, whether it's exercises
or touch, you have to adapt
based on what you're feeling and
similarly to what you ian
that brought it up before, the sort
of synchrony and whether it's exact or
not. Well, it sort of also depends on
the stimulus. There's a lot of research
that there was one paper that
was about a film and they got
two separate people to watch the same
film by themselves
at separate times, but in certain parts
of the film, their heart rate was
exactly the same. Their heart rate went
up when the fight scene happened and
then their heart rate went down the
same. And actually, you know, the
difference was they were in sync even
though they were nowhere near each
other, couldn't see each other, didn't
know what that person was doing.
They're probably doing completely
different things, but the stimulus
dictated the synchrony. So I think
that's an interesting thing to
consider as well, that the synchrony
might be from the stimulus that's
happening during the treatment, whether
it's touch, whether it's something else,
but we focused on touch. But yeah,
whether you synchronize just based on
what you're in that moment,
but actually it's completely different
otherwise. Yeah,
just wanted to point that out. Thanks.
That reminds me a lot of this direct
interfacing mechanism of synchrony,
which might be via, like auditory
communication, touch and so on. And then
there's this more stigma, g based niche
modification construction of a
niche, like a corn maze where everybody
walking through it is having a shared
experience. Or like you said, with two
people watching the same film. It's like
there's some similarity in their niche.
And so there's a resulting
synchronization without direct
interfacing because they're interacting
in a shared there's something shared
about their niche. Either two people
going through the same niche at
different moments, patients coming
through a space, or there's people that
are in separate physical spaces, but the
niche has some similarity. And I'm sure
there's a lot of other examples like
that. Ian. And then I have that image
up if you want to describe what you
wanted to share there. Thanks, Daniel.
Yeah, I will describe that in a moment.
But as conversation about films,
I'm just thinking that Hollywood and
filmmakers are actually masters of
inducing synchrony. Really. They've got
the birdsong, so they've got the
beautiful music or the dramatic music or
whatever. Got the imagery, the words,
the composition of the images to
hopefully not obviously not everyone
will have the same experience of a film.
But they hope that their sad film will
induce some synchrony amongst the
viewers in terms of the response in
their body. Or a happy film will induce
some kind of rhythmic and
I'm thinking about some work I've heard.
Of recently of John Viveki looking at
emotional goosebumps and how
this links to he thinks
the process of temperature regulation is
being exacted up into some kind of
relevant or bringing things salient to
us through goosebumps.
And there's an opportunity there to kind
of open up cognitively and explore some
other ideas that maybe the person wasn't
able to before. And you can think,
okay, that music gave me goosebumps,
and I had all these so, yeah, there's
just a few things as we were talking
there that I was thinking about. But
this diagram was, George, as you were
talking about, the kind of how the
complex things that might be at play
within a patient. This was done by MIT,
only found out about it a few days ago.
It was 2015. But all of these different
factors that might lead someone into a
kind of vicious cycle of depression.
And we've got things like cortisol
or unbridled inflammation at the top
there. But then you've also got, as you
said, George, the physical inactivity
and how this you've got all these
different looping perception action
cycles here that are creating this sort
of downward spiral. And therapeutically,
I guess what we're trying to do is
create an upward opening, trying to get
an access point. And Zoe, you said you
might have to try lots of looking,
trying one of these loops. And if that
doesn't work, okay, try a different loop
to open up this sort of thing that's
tightening and maybe open it up either
physically or perceptually.
Yeah. Thank you. This is like very much
showing that complex causation. And so
sometimes a disciplinary approach might
be like well, hippocampal volume is
associated with this change and that
could absolutely be empirically true or
cytokine signaling or early adverse
experiences. And so part of the
challenge is reassembling this complex
causal network. And then even if there
were some sort of causal network that
could be reassembled, then how
might the failure mode be similar
or different from the recovery mode?
Like there are certain things that
cannot be changed, like in the past and
there's other things kind of like the
concept of hysteresis where we can't
just reversibly modify something.
And so where are the leverage points in
this diagram? And it's
yeah, George, it.
Yeah, it's pretty complex, but yeah,
very good diagram for sure. And I think
there's a lot of stuff that we are
talking about that's clearly there I
think clearly we
have modifiable and non modifiable
things. There's stuff we can't change
someone else's genetics, we can't change
what happened in the past, okay? But
they are modifiable things that at least
in the context of musculoskeletal care
are present that can include beliefs,
their priors about their ideas about
pain, what's wrong with them and so on
down to things that could be lifestyle
and lifestyle could be more movement,
kind of changing the diet or whatever.
Stop smoking, kind of engaging in
something that starts getting them kind
of start getting their sense making
back. Okay. Through the
sense, the ideas. And actually the
other interesting thing about this stuff
where are the opportunities?
How can we start that process of change?
A very nice model, typically aligned
more with an activist approach now sort
of finding ways into pain and so on,
are the ecological psychology ideas
about affordances.
What is out there in the environment?
Already linked some authors to kind of
the active inference, predictive
processing and so on. But clearly one
can think about the world provides
us with a landscape of affordances
stuff that kind of are
opportunities for action, which is
basically what the description of an
affordance is and one that lives in a
very nice environment, for example,
with a beautiful park and can walk along
the coastline and stress
free environment and so on. Clearly that
world, it's a world for the sort of
beautiful kind of lifestyle and so on,
right? Whereas if one lives in an urban
jungle and everybody's super stressed
outside and so on, arguably that
landscape kind of is much smaller.
And when we say, yeah, would be good for
you to start walking, for example, that
would be a good way of start managing
your back pain. The patient can say,
yeah, but when I get out of the house,
I'm struggling. I might just get run
over by a car straight away. The
environment outside is awful. There's
pollution everywhere. What do you want
me to do?
I'm scared of going outside. So, no,
thank you very much. But of course, if
you are on the other side of the
spectrum, you can invite the person and
use what's out there and start playing a
little bit with those opportunities for
action. I think those
are tools that if we think sometimes we
can start thinking very hard about what
sort of exercises should the patient do,
should the person get engaged and so on.
And if we think much in much simpler
terms and think about what's outside,
what's out there, what kind of things
are already in the environment that can
be used to actually promote change,
we would be surprised that actually just
a flight of stairs would be good enough.
Don't take the lift. Take the stairs and
start sort of walking a little bit back
and forth from home to work and so on.
Those minimal things, if the person
feels like, yeah, okay, I'll have a go,
and I'll try that. Clearly we are in
that process of kind
of changing a little bit of their sort
of internal state. Maybe that prior
about, yeah, I can't move, I can't lift,
because it will damage my back. In fact,
when they start trusting their bodies,
they can do a little bit more.
It's always hard to think about, okay,
how can I change this? How can I change
the generative model? And we almost
think everything needs to be conscious,
cognitive and so on, when in fact, a lot
of stuff happens unconsciously. Right?
If it was always about, I'm going to
think about changing and I'm going to do
this, then the world would be much
simpler. Right. But a lot of stuff is
hidden anyway, and even the person is
not aware of that stuff.
So the change, the process, the tools
and so on, that goes
back to that very good diagram
with all these factors. And I think as a
practitioner, yes, okay. I can focus
entirely on the brain and the
neuroscience of it and become like a
brain centric approach, or I can start
thinking about actually the brain is
it's the hardware kind of stuff, but
there's much more in it and much more in
it. Takes the person, takes the
environment, takes the kind of
opportunities and so on. The stuff out
there can be used.
Thank you, George. Zoe?
Yeah. Just going off of what George said
in terms of the environment around it,
like when you're sort of maybe if you're
surrounded by nature or things like
that, then you might be sort of more
willing or more able to change your
priors. I think it's also important to
realize, especially through touch, that
it's one modality. Right. It's one way
in which we're starting to kind of try
to understand and try to manipulate
the process of sort of changing those
memories, whether it's the way it's
processed or just having initially or
just trying to adapt it. And that's that
touch is one way. But I think also
it's interesting that it's probably more
likely that we may not be able to
completely change that sort of prior,
but we might in that context. So we
might not change the fact that it's
painful to bend down, but we might be
able to, through touch and through sort
of treatment, get the patient to
realize, okay, well, yes, maybe bending
forwards is dangerous. It is a bad
thing. But if you do it in a certain way
and you look at it in this way, then
actually it's not so bad. So I
think it's important to take
the context into it. I think with this,
I think we might be able to maybe not
completely change the maladaptive
belief, but with touch we can try to
change it so that it's more context
specific rather than a general belief
that isn't able to change. We might be
able to change it. So in certain
circumstances, whether it's the way we
do things or just the way that we
approach things, we might be able to
update it or modify it for that specific
thing. I know that papers
were talking about it in terms of like
being scared of spiders. You might still
be scared of spiders, but if you know
that you're scared of spiders and
they've got food nearby and the spider
is happy, then maybe, yeah, the spider
is still scary, but it's not likely to
kill you or something like that. In this
circumstance, it's not as bad as it
could be and you're going to be safe
from whatever sort of fear it is. So I
think that's an important thing to
add on from what George was saying, and
I'll pass it back to George. Yes,
George. And then.
Know what Zoe just said.
It's quite important. And through touch
we can clearly get in kind of
affect, understand and so on. I think
that's all the positive stuff about
touch. There's another factor, another
side of the equation which I think as
practitioners we need to be aware of,
which is the power of what's the hidden
state and that touch can trigger.
And particularly in trauma situations,
memories are embodied. And when you
touch someone in a particular part of
the body, that might again bring that
unconscious stuff about. For example,
someone has been victim of sexual abuse
for example and you could touch a person
and straight away either there is a sort
of a massive response
fight or flight what's going on here?
Or if it is about this sort of
hidden state you might actually find
that that touch kind of created a
response that is almost like a no go
zone. And you kind of need to be aware
that sometimes you touch people that
don't like being touched. Someone goes
to a clinician that in an intervention
is primarily touch based, doesn't like
being touched, it might go well, it
might synchronize extremely well. They
understand you, they talk when you
start, say, okay, let's have a look.
Let's palpate that you can feel like
there's a fight or flight kind of mode.
The person goes in straight away. So I
think understanding this is
also quite important in understanding
the limits of competence of someone in
Musculoskeletal care, for example, that
that's an area that where probably the
person needs to be referred to someone
else, an expert in the area. Maybe by
getting a sense of there's a response
here. That's not the one I would expect
to perhaps not then to open the Pandora
box. Oh, tell me a little bit about
what's going on here because again,
you pressed on a button that keep
the lid on kind of thing. Don't open it,
please. This is important,
I think, both ways. It's kind of the
power as a therapeutic tool, but also
the power of triggering responses that
actually are quite important to
take into account. And in fact, the
paper we got accepted yesterday, which
is the continuation of this in
musculoskeletal care, one of the
reviewers actually wanted us to say
there are psychologists,
psychotherapy treat people, that
memories are embodied and you need to be
aware of avoiding overlaps. Okay? So
that means don't jump into an area that
you don't know about, but be aware that
sometimes you're getting that response
pretty much you're getting into someone
hidden state stuff that is there in the
background. Just leave it alone,
please. That's the way at least I see
the world around me is like don't
sort of start the process that you don't
want to or if you don't, if you do,
then go and see someone.
Or sorry, Ian. And then blue.
Oh, it's okay. I didn't have my hand up.
So over to blue. OK, blue, go for it.
So it's interesting, and I don't know if
in your work as an osteopath, but
there's many layers I found through
working emotionally, physically on
myself through my life. It's like
peeling an onion, right? And so as you
go through, it's interesting that all
this stuff resurfaces and even physical
trauma remains there. Like you stub your
pinky toe. You stub your pinky toe 25
times, 35 times, 255 times, who knows
how many times, right? It depends on how
clumsy you are. But your pinky toe
remembers being stubbed. It has maybe
like a hyper response because it's been
stubbed so many times, because it's
whatever that's its little job in life
is to be stubbed, I think. But it's
interesting that you kind of have to
open it up to do the work.
And I wonder what kind of synchronous
work there is. I know that there are
some people that deal with physical and
emotional trauma and I know physical
trauma can be a manifestation of
emotional trauma and you can have
emotional trauma based on your physical
trauma. So again, it's like this bi
directional circular loop and I
wonder what the training is in
osteopathy to deal with emotional trauma
that may come up or what kind of
are there people that do integrative
practices? Like you have to be an
osteopath and then maybe you do your
residency as a psychiatrist?
Can you get it all out if you have some
kind of linked problem that's both
physical and emotional?
Thank you, George. Then Ian.
Okay,
so the model in terms of therapeutic
alliance and synchrony and using touch
if we use to the whole world of
healthcare practice could argue that in
a world of psychotherapy for example
mind body kind of stuff the person
would be sort of equipped
with the tools to explore, to enable
them to open up, to start the process.
And being able to deal with that the
paper as a kind of a generic kind of
model that could apply as an umbrella to
a number of areas of practice. For sure,
we can do that and no problem. If we
think specifically about manual therapy
and specifically about osteopathy, then
you've got two worlds, the American
world of osteopathic medicine, where
osteopathic medicine is medicine. And
there are osteopaths in the US who are
psychiatrists as well. And in that case,
yes, that person would be ideally suited
to be able to explore that, to do that,
to kind of start that process of care,
actually using both their competences as
a psychiatrist and their competences as
also manual therapist as a hands on kind
of a practitioner. In other countries,
osteopaths are primarily kind of manual
therapists, if you want to call it that
way. Although osteopaths don't like
being called manual therapists, but
primarily use manual therapy primarily
in musculoskeletal care, but other areas
of practice. And we start seeing a
number of practitioners going down the
route of like physiotherapists using
what is called a psychologically
informed type of practice. And that
typically involves some additional
training in counseling or some
additional training in some CBT like
kind of approaches. Like, for example,
something like acceptance and commitment
therapy, for example. So stuff that
actually combined with hands on
potentiates the effect of the treatment
that the hands on alone would not
achieve. But when you come from the two
kind of two different angles meeting in
the middle and providing a more robust
package of care you can get better
results. Because the training
as a preregistration level is very
basic to enable
you to recognize that there are things
that need a referral
to another practitioner even those that
practice a psychologically informed type
of practice. Like several
physiotherapists have developed a kind
of a traffic light system where clearly
there are stuff on the yellow that
anxiety is associated with pain and so
on. That's okay, you can deal with that.
There's some stuff kind of in
the orange that you have to be a little
bit careful. And there are clearly stuff
PTSDs and so on,
where it's a no go zone because you
can dive in. And then you don't know if
you're going to come back okay kind of
thing. So that is typically a referral
to another practitioner. Having said
that, I think there are opportunities
for collaborative work where the two
together can actually provide a much
better service to a person that's simply
relying on one practitioner that can do
everything. I think that sometimes
exploring stuff through the physical
body, the embodied self opens the doors
for stuff to be explored at other
elements of the self when the body is a
little bit more prepared to deal with
stuff and people maybe are prepared to
talk. Sometimes you see that in cases of
childhood abuse and so on. Kind of
had some stuff that felt good, some
hands on work, even the massage and the
person felt a bit more confident in
themselves and they were prepared then
let's have a chat. And they were not
prepared to sort of go to talking
therapy straight away because there was
too much going on in there. Kind of
invited itself. The sirens
go off when certain things happen.
Exactly. Ian.
Yes. So just sort of picking up on the
points from George and the question from
yeah really totally agree that it's not
the job of an untrained manual therapist
to kind of aim to open a
can of worms of something that
especially if it's not five minutes
before the end of a session, and then
you kind of say, okay, I want to see you
later, see you next week, and got
another client now, and that's
definitely not a good idea. However, as
you said, George, sometimes people will
come and they'll want to offer things
and they'll want to talk about stuff.
And what I was thinking about Blue as
you were asking about sort of the
different combinations of approaches. I
don't know if George and Zoe or any of
you are familiar with David Bocelli's
work on tre trauma release or tension
release.
You know, he doesn't really go into the
story. So it's not kind of
psychoanalytical or unraveling the
stories of people's past. But he has
methods for inducing kind of what
I think is myofascial and what it looks
like myofascial unwinding. So sometimes
it's tremoring and
so it's sort of I don't think he
necessarily uses touch in the beginning,
but I guess what
I'm thinking is that there are ways that
if the ways of offering clients
opportunities to unravel the
bodily trapped or the stuff
that's held in the body where they don't
have to verbalize it if they don't want
to. But the inroad is to
induce some kind of letting go, which
maybe is what all manual therapy is
about, to a greater or lesser degree.
But his examples are quite dramatic.
People will be making big movements that
seemingly are uncontrolled but if you
ask them to stop at any time, they can
stop. They can bring it into voluntary.
But there seems to be a really big
updating of some generative model
through this process.
Yeah, they're my thoughts.
Thank you. I'm going to return to our
previous complex causation network.
Now, it's smaller because we're
abstracting away from the details and
think about, like, what are some active
inference questions that come to mind
and how could we look at this
differently than, for example, just a
structural equation model that's fit
from many empirical studies? And so
here's Figure 4.3 from the textbook.
And this is a partially observable
Markov decision process. And it's come
up in other papers and live streams, so
we won't go into too much details. But
the kinds of things that we might want
to ask are, like, what variables are
latent states or observable in general?
And then in the specific case, for
example, maybe there's a total,
absolutely perfect association between
hippocampus volume and some other
clinical outcome. And so hippocampus
volume conceptually is observable. It
could be observed. But in that exact
patient's case, it may not be an
observable in that relationship. So
variables can be observable in one
context and latent in another context.
So that might speak to evidence based
grounding where like, okay, we don't
know what somebody's blood level of this
is, what's the most informative thing to
do? Maybe we can measure it. And then
that ties their measurements into other
observables. So that's one question.
What are observables and what are latent
variables? What variables do we have
causal influence on? What affordances
exist that might have intervening
influence on some unobserved state? So
here's, like, pi the policy selection
and then the way that the hidden state
is changing through time. That's what
the affordances are about. Influencing
the hidden state is the true temperature
of the room. The thermometer is the
observed value. And then taking an
action like turning on the air
conditioning is about intervening in the
hidden state such that other observables
are seen. And then we talked also about
like, in what ways can we change the
generative model? So here's the policy
selection of the practitioner. And then
in the interface, it's like, it's
meeting with the observations of
the patient. The actions of the
practitioner, what they say and what
they do are received as observations.
And that's kind of this dyad active that
we've seen. So rather than the one
entity navigating and sense making in
the world, the joint sense making
features, this interface where the
policy selections on one and their
thinking through other minds, their
inference on the generative model of the
other is what is being intervened in.
How can we change the generative model,
the cognitive models? How can we change
the generative process? Could there be
something welcoming on the door of
the room that is a modification of the
niche or some other design choice that
helps scaffold this therapeutic niche?
And yeah, what policies can be taken
from the toolkit that is afforded in
that moment based upon the training and
the equipment available and so on, that
influence what to result in what.
And that kind of comes back to this
synchrony for what question? Just
achieving synchrony is like a sort of
undirected hypnosis or
undirected sort of I don't know,
it's just sort of like this vegetative
propagation of coordination that
would only coincidentally be functional.
So having a functional outcome in mind,
then there can be a working backwards,
like well, what observations are we
looking for? And then what hidden states
give rise to those observations? And
what policies exist that intervene in
those hidden states and in the dynamics
of how they change, recognizing their
complexity? So those would just be a few
active inference variables and
approaches that are being invoked here
conversationally. However, the kinds of
models and the empirical data to take it
further are being sketched out.
Well, it's going very fast and we're in
kind of the home stretch. So what would
anyone like to look at or
turn to? We have a few other questions
that previously had been raised that we
didn't perhaps get to. Some of them
are written here, so anything that
people see here that they're interested
in or any other topic. And then also
just how are we coming out of this dot?
Two what will be different in our action
as we are engaged in this area, of
course, from many different
perspectives. George.
I loved your kind of proposal, your
summary of all those active inference
questions. In fact, there's a structure
for paper in it, right?
It can take us down the road, even just
sort of looking at some computational
stuff. So creating some kind of a
framework. Yeah, so I very much
like it. I think there is a sort
of challenge and what are the latents
and observables and so on to define
those kind of things? That needs a
little bit of thinking.
The other stuff, I think, as you said,
probably working backwards would sort of
becomes easier, isn't it?
It is about hands on with reassurance
and so on. If that's sort of what the
policy and so on and what we observed
back at the beginning, I think it would
be fascinating. I think in terms of the
bio behavioral kind of element of
synchrony, there's clearly changes in
breathing, changes in probably heart
rate variability and so on.
That would be interesting to understand.
Is that a sign that the system is sort
of starting, changing the
process? It talked about the thing,
maybe something in the door of the room.
A couple of years ago when I was
practicing in another country for
quite a few months, I used to use a lot
of classical music and opera and so on.
And that was actually a tremendously
effective way of creating an environment
where the person sort of actually a form
of inducing that synchrony.
I'm treating I'm kind of doing this
stuff. I don't need to talk that much.
I'm kind of just go with the sensations,
go with the music. And I felt that
actually that was a very good way as a
process of start changing the generative
model. So there is the
stuff, as we kind of proposed
on one of the recent papers, the stuff
that you can implement. So if you doing
the Tactile, the touch based
intervention and use forms of language
sometimes to get the person
to visualize what you're doing, for
example, I'm doing this and I'm trying
to achieve that. And you know that the
person is even, like, interceptively
robust enough to let you explore the
inner sensations to situations as
you're probably doing some work. And you
realize by sort of predicting their
internal states that they're just
focusing too much and giving too much
attention to stuff which is actually not
useful, where you can just say, oh, you
know what? Like we said in the paper, I
have a new dog. And where does the dog
come from? But a dog in that sense is a
way of sort of breaking down that
attention to what you're doing to sort
of say oh, okay, so you're continuing,
there's still the sensory stimulation,
there is still that sensory evidence
arriving to the system. But actually you
start changing a little bit, you're
flattening a little bit of the sensory
state by sort of zeroing things and then
maybe those sensations that come in
potentially kind of change some stuff.
So yeah, I think at this level that's
for sure some stuff to do.
I think it's an interesting thing that
actually started being explored now with
Ted Kapchuk lab in Harvard around
Acupuncture, which know looking at
synchrony as well with hyperscanning
techniques and kind of finding that
actually successful in terms of the
intervention is associated again, what
synchrony. So kind of a
body of evidence sort of building up, I
think quite nice.
One thought on the free energy
minimizing and ML Don and several others
were discussing in the chat about our
biological systems truly finding global
minima. And so it's a big question, but
just to give one thought on it is the
free energy is calculated for
a given policy sequence of actions in
terms of how informative that sequence
of actions is expected to be and how
useful that sequence of action is
supposed to be expected to be. And so
different action pathways are evaluated
based upon their ability to reduce
uncertainty or provide direct value.
And so if we can just maybe there's
multiple things that have value in the
therapeutic alliance, but one for the
generative model of the practitioner
might be like to reduce a number on a
pain survey that would be useful and
then there might be multiple policies
and maybe adequacy is good enough. And
if the pathways are to some
balance or shifting balance of
informative and useful, either reducing
pain or helping understand how to reduce
pain, then navigating and shifting
policies is something that can be done
adaptively. And then in contrast, the
policies that might want to be
disfavored would be like the ones that
are adding confusion, reducing clarity
of sense making or increasing pain.
And that's not to say that there's not
moments where transiently surprise does
increase or pain does increase, but that
is part of a policy like, I'm going to
touch this place, that might transiently
increase pain, but that might be an
informative action that in an extended
timeline is part of a free energy
minimizing trajectory. And so what is
the horizon and so on. George and
then anyone else?
That thing sort of modifying pain,
modifying symptoms. It's quite an
interesting thing because for example,
at least in my profession, there's this
idea that we don't treat the symptoms,
we treat the cause of the problem.
Okay, so pain is just the symptoms,
nothing to worry about.
But from this perspective, actually
changing symptoms, reducing symptoms is
actually an important thing, quite an
important thing. Particularly if you're
thinking about chronic conditions. If
you start making the person start
feeling a little bit better, then you
probably start changing the
whole process. If you don't change
anything, how is the person going to
engage in that? If actually you can
continue saying you're moving much
better, your function is so much better,
but actually the person says, you know
what, but pine hasn't reduced at all.
I'm still in agony. I think going a
little bit with small things at that
level are quite important in the greater
scheme of things in terms of changing
the generative model. So it
is clearly a fundamental bit of
the jigsaw. And it's the same as you
said, informing, for example, this might
be uncomfortable, but in fact is
important in kind of
achieving something. So the same way
some patients tell you it is painful,
but it's a good pain. So again, what's
the value of the good pain is, the
reward is a sort of anticipation that
this will lead to a positive change.
Thank you. Zoe?
Yeah, I think George just kind of
touched upon what I was going to know.
Sometimes patients I know, I have
patients that come to a session and they
expect it to be painful. I mean, a lot
of people expect that at some point they
might get that sort of, quote,
good pain where they almost
want to feel like something's happening.
And whether that feedback is kind of
pain or something, that's kind of
reassuring. I know patients, especially
with sort of osteopathic, manipulative
sort of treatment,
they want the click. If someone
manipulates them, they come in and go,
oh, I just want you to click me. And,
you know, the research shows that not
necessarily you need that sound, but
that feedback that they sort of want.
They kind of want some people, they
expect if you do a hard, sort of a
more firm massage, they feel like
they're, I don't know, getting their
money's worth or they're getting more
sort of treatment than if they want.
They kind of want that feedback to say,
yeah, you're in the right place, and I
get that a lot. So I think pain is an
interesting one. I think the
biosynchrony that we get and we go upon,
whether it is the patient's heart rate,
their breathing changes, you see their
facial expression changes or the muscle
tightens up nearby, you kind of go on
that. And I think it's what they expect
to get from treatment. Not every patient
is going to come in and go, yeah, I want
to be in less pain. That might not be
their ultimate goal. Obviously they're
not going to say no to it, but they
might really just want to be able to
pick their kid up or go to sleep with
just being able to go to sleep, not
being in pain or not waking up or
something like that. So I think it's not
yes, we can clinically,
it's not so simple as something that we
can measure imperatively. It might be
something that a goal
to that patient is more important than
if their pain is less or if they're
moving better or oh, well, yeah,
if we had the technology to say, look.
Oh, look, your heart. Rate is lower. Or
this means that you're more efficient.
You're saving free energy because you're
not expending on your pain. Or you're
more efficient, so you'll have more
energy to do this. Now that you're doing
this better, they may not care. They may
just want to be able to pick their kid
up and not be in pain. So I think
what we're measuring, I think, will be
very individual to the patient and it
might not be something that is
necessarily useful in terms of research
that we can quantify. It just might be
that goal that's not always sort of
empirical. Thank you,
Zoe. Ian.
Thanks. Thanks, all. And, yeah,
just as you were saying that, Zoe, you
said at the beginning, I think the
intention behind it all is to help them.
And I'm just thinking of a scenario or
some scenarios of when agreeing
on the goals is so important. So I'm
thinking short term goals and long term
goals here. So clients who are maybe
endurance runners, and they want to do
six ultramarathons a year and they come
to you because their calves are hurting,
so your immediate goal is to reduce the
pain in their calves so they can make
the ultramarathon at the end of the
month. But then if
I'm aware as a therapist that there's a
link between endurance running and
developing arrhythmias, heart
arrhythmias, for example, and I see this
person is very anxious about their goals
to the point where it's almost like they
need it rather than it's a
pleasure. As such, then if
I disagree with their goal,
are we am I true? You know, and saying,
actually, maybe four ultramarathons a
year would be enough for you. Am I just
enabling this drive by relieving
your calf pain in the short term?
So I think agreeing on those
more broader life goals or referring
to someone else if I don't agree with
that, that's more
of an ethical issue. But it came to mind
as we were talking there. Yeah, that
reminds me of the kind of performances
that we might see in the Olympics or the
medical care that might happen on the
sideline of a game where somebody has
been injured, but they're going to
continue doing it almost in a
way that is rapidly degrading
potentially the future weeks of their
health. And then that's the ethical
challenge or the decision making
challenge. Like is it worth them
to hobble across the finish line with an
injury? That every step is just
deteriorating the injury, but then being
consistent with a belief that one is a
finisher or even a signal to those who
are watching. There's so many complex
phenomena at that level.
Those are very interesting questions.
Wow. So we're towards the end
here, I guess for the authors and for
anyone else, we can give some of our
last thoughts. What are some of your
next directions for this line of
research and application?
Okay, well, first of all,
as last time was a fascinating
discussion, think kind of learning a
lot from this kind of interaction.
For sure.
Within this we sort
of got some stuff done published in the
musculoskeletal side of things. We have
another paper to be submitted very soon,
the next week or so, the same topic,
but in pediatrics. And there's the bulk
of the other stuff building up. I think
what we want to achieve now is to start
testing some of these ideas kind of
empirically using different methods from
qualitative kind of phenomenological
type of approaches, trying to understand
really what's going on to more sort
of NeuroBio stuff.
Kind of along the lines of looking at
for example, some markers of
bio behavioral synchrony like for
example,
physiological changes in both the
practitioner and the patient.
Bearing in mind some of this stuff.
It is a bit more challenging to achieve
because whereas for example, in the
field of psychotherapy, the person
practitioner is typically sitting down,
the guy doing manual therapy is moving
around. So therefore the heart rate is
not going to be exactly the same but
looking at what can be done and
creating some models as well.
So the idea around computational stuff
also makes sense to test some
of the ideas. This is work that is
building up. So we very much look
forward to kind of people getting in
touch, bouncing off ideas from
each other, kind of looking at how we
can move forward with this. It's not
osteopathic specific is more than
that. I think at least it can be manual
therapy more broadening
along those lines. You can look at sort
of the role of some of this stuff in
chronic conditions, not just pain, but
other persistent physical symptoms and
so on. So that's where we are. It's time
now to start kind of testing some of
this stuff for sure and stop writing
theoretical papers.
Cool. Zoe?
Yeah, sort of what George said.
We've had one paper accepted for MSK,
so hopefully that will come out for
everyone to read soon. What is MSK.
We've got one waiting,
so for more orthopedic
general musculoskeletal muscle muscle
and bones kind of patients and
then the pediatrics one is almost ready
to submit. And then, yeah, I guess we'll
be looking towards seeing where it goes
and what we can sort of empirically
prove from all the theories that are
kind of circulating and
going from there. But hopefully
discussions like what everyone said now
will give everyone more ideas to. Sort
of. Where we're going or where we could
go, and different ways to apply the
principles and the frameworks that we've
suggested so far. Awesome.
George? Yeah. Just on the pediatrics,
we actually have one of the first lines
to start exploring is synchrony between
mother, baby and practitioner.
Starting with not sure if you're going
to we've been doing a
bit of work around the effect of touch
on premature babies. So we have those
collaborations with hospitals in Italy
would enable us to do some of that
stuff. But we sort of start looking also
looking at this whole concept of
synchrony on a triadic kind of
thing so the baby, the practitioner and
the mother and see if actually if we
find that the synchrony actually between
mother and baby is a marker of for
example, the baby would be some
markers of autonomic change,
changes in autonomic arousal, for
example. Like we observed, for example,
the effect of effective touch, gentle
touch on the baby sat and so on. Thank
you, Ian.
George, just as you were saying about
the challenge of a practitioner being
moving whilst during a manual therapy
session and I'm sort of aware of how
that does lead to some difficulties,
especially with the PPG sort of
measurement of heart rate variability.
I heard just an idea I heard about, I
don't know if you've come across it a
wearable ECG that it's
aimed at increasing respiratory sinus
arrhythmia. It vibrates and it
stimulates the person, catches them at
the top of their outbreath and it's
designed to actually be used whilst
you're walking around in everyday life.
So I'm just wondering if there's an
opportunity there because
it's designed to A, increase RSA
and B to be used whilst moving.
That might be an interesting piece of
kit to use.
Yeah, absolutely.
Cool. Blue or would anyone else
like any comments?
I just want to give a final thought.
So something that I'm going to be
thinking about for, I don't know,
whoever knows how long is this idea of
the emotional and physical body in
terms of reference point.
Right, so we studied in, I think, Live
Stream 40, the FEP for Generic Quantum
Systems, and it talked about how
the FEP drives entanglement and
in this way, when there's perfect
learning, there's this overlapping of
the reference point. So I just wonder,
how can an emotional body and a physical
body be driven toward a more overlapping
reference frame when those things are so
fundamentally different? So I'm going to
be thinking about that.
Cool. Very cool.
All right, well, thank you for this
excellent two. That concludes
44 and really appreciated the
authors joining. And Blue, thank you for
joining Ian, also for contributing so
much with the dot zero. And everyone is
welcome back to give us updates on their
learning and application on this very
important area. So thanks again,
everybody. See you later. Thank you.
Thank you. Goodbye.